e como piloto de automobilismo a minha
briga sempre foi contra o relógio
milésimos de segundo fazer a diferença
entre a Vitória EA derrota mas hoje quem
dita o de O tempo das minhas conquistas
é a natureza na vida Eu sempre tive duas
grandes paixões o automobilismo EA
conservação a paixão pela conservação
Começou quando eu tinha apenas 12 anos
eu fui para a África com meu pai fazer
um Safari e na época não tinha esses
hotéis lindos como é hoje com piscina no
quarto e tudo isso muito pelo contrário
a gente passou 15 dias na caçamba de um
caminhão no Serengeti um dos maiores
parques da Tanzânia acampando no meio
dos animais
e é tomando banho só quando achava uma
cachoeira Eu corri por quase 20 anos
cheguei a ser piloto de teste de Fórmula
1 campeão inglês de Fórmula 3 e correr
alguns anos de Fórmula Indy mas eu
sempre soube que quando me aposentasse
eu queria trabalhar com conservação eu
não tenho nenhuma formação de biólogo de
veterinário mas sempre fui interessado
na conservação eu tirei dois anos
sabáticos Viajando o mundo inteiro para
tentar ver os animais que eu queria ver
na natureza e nunca tinha tido tempo
e eu fui para a China ver os Panda urso
polar no norte do Canadá tigres na Índia
até gorilas na Uganda enfim eu fui ver
todos os bichos que você pode imaginar
mas o grande x da questão é ela que eu
queria entender o que que estava sendo
feito para conservar todos esses animais
e foi na África do Sul que eu encontrei
um modelo sustentável que eu queria
trazer para o Brasil o que acontecia na
África 40 anos atrás é muito parecido
com o que acontece hoje em dia no Brasil
Mais especificamente no Pantanal a maior
planície inundável do mundo na África
assim como no Pantanal eles tinham a
pecuária como maior fonte de renda tinha
também criação de ovelha e até caça
esportiva e assim como acontece hoje em
dia no Brasil lá na África eles matavam
leões leopardos e guepardos em
Retaliação a esses animais comerem os
animais
e no Brasil apesar de legal no Pantanal
até hoje em dia bolsas pintadas são
mortas Tudo Mudou lá na África quando um
cara chamado John Barth resolveu
habituar uma leopardo isso quer dizer
que ele começou a seguir essa leopardo
por meses por anos até que ela parou de
perceber o carro dele com turistas como
uma ameaça ele fez uma pousada na
fazenda dele Essa pousada ficou cheia
era o único lugar no mundo onde se podia
se ver o Leopardo na natureza com o
tempo o turismo lá foi crescendo ele fez
mais uma pousada e o grande negócio que
aconteceu quando nasceu os filhotes
desse leopardo os filhotes nascerão
copiando o comportamento da mãe ou seja
Eles nasceram habituados isso incentivou
mais ainda o ecoturismo na região os
vizinhos entenderam que o John na
fazenda dele que chama londolozi tava
ganhando
tô trabalhando pela natureza a favor da
natureza Então os vizinhos copiaram o
modelo fizeram pousadas em também e suas
fazendas e tudo virou uma grande área de
conservação privada hoje em dia
conhecida como substance que fica
vizinha ou Kruger Park o maior parque
nacional da África do Sul a minha ideia
era trazer esse modelo para o Brasil o
modelo auto-sustentável que
desenvolvesse o ecoturismo a teoria era
que precisava se ver onças pintadas na
natureza na mesma forma que ninguém vai
para a África para ver uma zebra pouca
gente vinha para o Brasil para ver uma
capivara então que o estímulo do
ecoturismo a gente conseguiria tornar o
Pantanal mais auto-sustentável
e o turismo no Brasil ainda super
subdesenvolvido para gente ter uma ideia
tem mais gente que visita o museu do
Louvre em Paris do que o Brasil seja lá
por que motivo for em 2011 eu fundei
onçafari a ideia era desenvolver o
ecoturismo e fazer com que as outras
fossem vistas pelas pessoas na natureza
o plano funcionou super bem e onde se
viam apenas seis ou sete vezes onça por
ano no Refúgio Ecológico Caiman a
principal base de uma Safari hoje se vê
mais de 900 vezes 98 por cento dos
hóspedes que nos visitaram em 2019 viram
pelo menos pelo menos uma onça na
natureza e tudo isso fez com que
aumentasse ocupação das pousadas em
duzentos e setenta por cento gerando
emprego não só para homem mas também
para as mulheres que na pecuária às
vezes ficam deixadas de lado isso ajudou
e as mulheres e os homens a terem Mais
Emprego mas famílias inteiras a gente
tem vários casos na Cayman onde mostram
que o homem da família que sustentava a
casa hoje melhorou de emprego indo da
pecuária para seguir de turismo e
ganhando mais a mulher tem emprego por
exemplo de cozinheira nas pousadas a
filha de arrumadeira e o filho na
manutenção ou treinando para ser Dias
muito dessas pessoas antigamente caçavam
onças mas hoje eles entendem que a onça
vale muito mais viva do que morta se
você falar para um deles hoje em dia que
você vai caçar uma onça-pintada é melhor
você sair correndo porque senão ele vai
caçar é você esse processo de
desenvolver o ecoturismo deu Tão certo
que hoje ou um safári trabalha não só no
Pantanal mas também na Amazônia na Mata
Atlântica e até no cerrado onde a gente
faz o mesmo processo com o lobo-guará
animals
é aquele bioma
e com crescimento do projeto a gente
desenvolveu outras áreas hoje além do
ecoturismo a gente tem ciência educação
melhorias sociais preservação de
florestas e até reintrodução fomos os
primeiros do mundo a conseguir
reintroduzir onças-pintadas na natureza
parece um plano fácil mas na verdade
algo inédito no mundo se você reproduz
um por exemplo ele sai pastando e
isso é algo natural já uma onça-pintada
tem que aprender com a mãe como caçar e
todas essas que a gente que introduziu
não tinha uma mãe então a gente teve que
desenvolver fórmulas e métodos para
ensinar essas onças a caçar em a Isa e a
Fera as duas primeiras que introduzidas
no Pantanal já tiveram filhotes na
natureza provando que o projeto Foi um
sucesso a gente foi aplicou esse
processo também na Amazônia e agora o
objetivo é fazer também na Mata
Atlântica onde as onças corre
o perigo eu corri a mais de 320 km por
hora hoje eu ando devagar no tempo dos
animais eu entendi que a natureza tem o
seu próprio tempo tempo de se reformular
de se regenerar e se transformar
e eu ainda corro contra o tempo
o tempo de preservar os animais
desenvolver socioeconomicamente as
regiões onde a gente trabalha e tempo de
deixar um legado um legado positivo para
as futuras gerações Muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
E aí